et que beaucoup oublient vite la suite
d'un magicien on revient
zuber toit de l'eau de l'eau qui part
derrière le paysage c'est pas mal ça va
je sais pas c'est pas terrible mais
c'est bien ce contrat du noir du bien au
classement
on va revenir m'attendais reparti c'est
pas pour toi tu es vraiment un tout
petit truc qu'on fera un petit truc en
partant non le prendre par derrière dans
le barrage on voit bien que nous
trouvons exactement c'est super ça va
anwar est important car on n'est pas
violée par l'arrière je leur prends par
l'arrière en partant
je veux me rendre à saint-jean a besoin
mais c'est pas que je vais rentrer
plus large que leurs surplus barre pour
la gauche pour descendre le revo ça peut
que taper à bras le corps et kossou la
gauche camara est l'étendard à combelles
fait à puce peut désormais des barrages
de parent sur le banc grands pôles
encore à gorron encore encore encore
encore que la de loin à la seule alors
que l'apa le patin de hockey on doit
tout à fait un petit plan comme ça le
sort du sort de l'impasse
sortis sains et saufs en est on va
tourner vers la droite
voilà voilà ok c'est bon pour nous à
droite on est parti
alors mesdames génial à un titulaire de
bordeaux on a un peu contre le futur
statut dans la gauche de bellac soit pas
trop quand tu es d'accord ont tué à la
gauche l'avait agosti togo que la droite
va bien le vert
le bloc l'acier glisse pour sa galerie à
tous les radiologues pour l'akp et attal
placier du d'ailleurs quand tu montes un
petit peu de voir le placier attribué à
douala
un enfant né de la gamme
la terre elle edouard viii dont la voix
devant elle et pas seulement du bout du
lac de l'endre notre endroit paisible ce
que ce deal qui sont dans l'art d'un
code de la lave et s'auto verte
on a toutefois le temps voilà ça vous
coûte vers un plan assez assez assez
dramatique
un petit peu plus un peu plus larges
couloirs de vent d'où là juste en bas
dans le même axe j'ai les cartes l'an
passé vachement beau ou écarte toi max
et carpes koi vas-y fais-le viste de
l'ordre on est passé à côté d'un truc en
dessous du lit copd magnifique avec un
premier plan c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon et de maroilles quand on la voit un
peu ce pas là devant vous
il a partout elle épousera et petit sont
les cocus mémoire vente à ses côtés d'un
tout qui l'attend en a qui vont devoir
requérir le petit
le fait d'apprendre qu'il est tombé dans
le champ dessus et commence
enfin leur route
petit la queue